hey guys I am alone in my apartment
today which means I can actually go
ahead and record yet another video so
welcome back because we're going to be
doing some more low-level design and for
today's video we are going to be doing a
parking garage implementation so as a
kid from New York City I'm not the best
of drivers I definitely have a lot of
trouble with parallel parking
um and I would have to say that you know
when it comes to fitting in tight spaces
I've always definitely empathized more
with the parking spot than the car I
tend to prefer other people do the work
there so without further Ado let's go
ahead and get into this challenge there
are a ton of different functional
requirements for a problem like this so
I'll name the ones that I'm going off of
but maybe you know in a natural
interview they might extend this problem
quite a bit and so it's possible that
I'm not going to cover everything but
I'll do my best to you know address
different aspects of this problem where
I can so let's go ahead and get into it
okay starting off a parking garage so we
all know what it is basically that's
where you go when you have a car and you
need to go ahead and start or it
somewhere while you go out and do your
thing but generally speaking what are
the functional requirements of this
problem basically we want to design some
sort of parking lot that has three major
requirements we want to be able to enter
the lot as a car and basically receive a
spot to take at the moment of Entry
right so we would get a ticket from the
entry and it would tell us which spot to
take similarly we want to be able to
exit a lot and then the last kind of
piece of this puzzle is also just you
know if you're driving around and are
considering entering a lot to be able to
see how many available spots there are
of each type so I'm going to assume
there are three types of spots we can
call those big medium and small and for
now just to simplify things I'm going to
assume that only big vehicles can fit in
big spots medium and medium spots and
small in small spots but this doesn't
really complicate the problem too much
and again different interviewers might
have different requirements here perhaps
some would say like oh you know a small
vehicle could go in a big spot but
ideally we should prioritize the small
spots first so that could complicate
things a little bit but for now I'm not
really going to consider that okay so
let's think about the actual parking
garage itself so we know that we want
our parking garage to probably be an
interface the reason for that being that
amongst parking garages we've kind of
standardized the way that a user might
interact with it right they're just
going up to the entry and exit point and
asking for a ticket or giving them back
their ticket or seeing how many
available spots there are but within
that actual interface that a user might
use to interact with the parking garage
we don't actually know how the
implementation is going to happen under
the hood so it's important that we kind
of have the standardized interfaces so
that users can interact with it in kind
of a normalized way but under the hood
we may actually determine the way that
parking spots are given out in multiple
different types of implementations and
as a result interfaces are probably the
way to go here so if we are actually
going to have an interface as our
parking garage what are those three main
methods going to look like that we have
to be implementing well the first one is
going to be to actually enter the garage
that is going to take in something like
a car size an entry number because it's
possible that a parking garage might
have multiple entrances and exits and
then also a license plate number and
basically what this is going to mean is
that you know a car with a given license
plate is coming in through a certain
entry number and that car has a given
size and all our parking garage is going
to do is going to return the name of the
actual spot that it is that they're
going to be taking
similarly we also have this concept of
exiting and that's when a car is leaving
the parking garage it's going to give
back its ticket which has basically its
license plate number and also its car
size and entry number and then we can go
ahead and basically vacate that spot
again and say this is now open for
future cars to take the last piece of
this puzzle is actually getting the
number of spots we don't need any
methods for this parameter because more
or less all that's going to happen is
we're just going to display a map of you
know car size medium 100 spots car size
small 10 spots so it's just going to
tell you how many available spots there
are for each size
um do we actually need any other classes
well to get started we probably don't
need a vehicle class the reason for this
being that um you know in our case
Vehicles actually aren't holding any
stateful information uh the vehicle
itself is not really part of the parking
garage but what really is is actually
the parking spot because we need to know
if a given parking spot is occupied or
it's not and also certain aspects about
the parking spot such as its distance to
each entry or exit and so let's go ahead
and take a look at a parking spot class
so here are some of the actual fields
that might be really useful for us as
you can see we have this parking spot
and then it's going to come with a size
so I'm assuming a size is part of this
size enum which could be something like
small medium or big it's going to have a
name and that name is going to come in
handy if we ever need to use something
like a hash map from parking spot names
to parking spots and then also finally I
have this concept of a list of distance
to entrances so imagine that we have you
know five entrances this list distance
to entry is going to have a
corresponding distance in who knows say
meters from this particular parking spot
to every single one of those five
entrances so you know distance to
entrances at the zeroth index would be
basically the distance to that first
entrance of the parking lot
okay so let's think about some possible
implementations of our parking garage
because we've said that this is an
interface there's definitely many
different ways that we can go ahead and
assign spots and as a result of that
some are going to be better than others
and some are maybe going to have some
algorithmic complexity trade-offs and
some are going to have some practical
trade-offs so let's think about one that
would have really good algorithmic
complexity well a simple naive way of
assigning spots would basically just to
maintain cues for every single type of
spot right so we would have a queue for
the small spots a cue for the medium
spots and a q for the large spots and
basically as cars come in and request
spots we just go ahead and assign the
first element of that queue to them and
then remove it from the queue this is
really nice because this implementation
is in O of one time we don't have to do
any thinking about what the best spot to
assign someone is but rather we just go
ahead and give them one basically
randomly using something like a queue
which is effectively just saying like
what is the least recently used spot
let's go ahead and give you that so that
works well and it'll definitely give
everyone a spot but practically speaking
that's not that great the reasoning
being that these spots are basically
going to be put in the queue randomly
and what if I'm entering through a
parking lot entrance that is really
close to a few spots wouldn't it be
better if I assigned a user a spot that
was actually closer to that entrance and
if this is kind of the case that you
want what we can instead do is use a
priority queue data structure so this is
really useful in the sense that using a
priority queue or basically A Min Heap
under the hood is going to allow us to
quickly find The Parking Spot object
that has the least distance to that
entrance now the issue here is that I've
mentioned that there are multiple
possible entrances in our parking garage
and you know each entrance is also going
to have a corresponding exit but let's
not worry about that for the moment and
as a result we're going to have to
maintain many different cues or many
different priority cues rather showing
the distances to each one of those
entrances and so every single time that
a car is entering from a given entrance
we have to pull up the correct priority
queue both for the corresponding size of
the car and also the corresponding
entrance and once we go ahead and figure
out which spot is being assigned to that
car we then have to remove that parking
spot not only from the priority queue
for that entrance but also from the
priority queue for all of the other
entrances and for us to do that in a
relatively efficient way we have to
maintain a hash map from a parking spot
name to basically its location in all of
those priority queues so that we can
relatively quickly remove that node from
all of them
another possibility that I cover on this
slide though I won't touch upon it too
much is that we can actually kind of
Shard up our parking lot so if we have
many entrances throughout the parking
lot and they're all in different zones
per se we could basically make it so
that only a single entrance is allowed
to assign spots from a single zone so
let's say I have this massive parking
lot it's a big rectangle and I have an
entrance on the left side and an
entrance on the right side I could split
my parking lot down in the middle and
only assign spots from the left side to
one entrance and spots from the right
side from the other entrance and they
won't basically go ahead and you know
take spots from each other's Zone the
final possibility or the final thing to
think about is depending on how this
parking lot is implemented and you know
if it's possible that multiple entrances
can be assigning the same spots we may
actually have to think about doing some
sort of locking or dealing with thread
safe programming in the sense that we
don't want the same spot to be assigned
twice there could be a race condition
there where if two cars arrive at
basically the same time you know they
may end up being assigned the same spot
and that can't happen so it's possible
that you would have to actually do some
locking here but for the sake of this
problem we're not really focusing as
much on the concurrent programming
aspect of things and more so on the
object-oriented design
okay so I'm actually going to go ahead
and now implement this concept of a
priority queue parking lot right where
we're trying to assign the closest spot
to each entrance that's still available
and this is going to get a little bit
confusing I do use some pseudo code
because the reality is coding this would
actually not be that easy but I'm going
to try and do my best to explain it in a
way that makes sense to you all so
basically we're going to have the
following so let's imagine we have our
priority queue parking lot and the
Constructor is basically going to take
in a list of parking spot objects and
also a number of entrances right so the
first thing that we have is this concept
of a car map for now I'm going to say
the car map is just an internal field
and it's going to maintain a mapping
from basically car license plate number
to the actual parking spot object that
that car is located in but then
furthermore we want to make sure that
for every single parking spot in our
garage and also for all of the number of
entrances we want to be basically
putting that parking spot in the
corresponding queue or priority queue
that belongs to it so firstly what we're
going to do is go ahead and add it to
the priority queue and then also once we
have the index in that priority queue
just keep in mind that priority cues are
implemented as Min heaps which are
basically just arrays under the hood we
need to know the actual index of the
array that that parking spot was placed
in the reasoning for this being that
we're going to constantly be removing
things from multiple cues and when we're
removing them from the priority queues
they're not necessarily at the root node
of that Heap and so in order to still
maintain a o of log n complexity as
we're removing nodes from the priority
queue we have to actually know exactly
where they're located in the priority
queue before removing them otherwise we
would have to do a linear find for that
parking spot in the priority queue and
then we would ruin our time complexity
so it's very important that we keep some
data structure that allows us to see
where these parking spot nodes are in
every single queue in terms of their
actual index so that's what the parking
spot hashmap does it goes ahead and says
okay for a given parking spot name and
also the actual entrance where is that
location in the priority queue and then
additionally we're also just going to go
ahead and add all of these parking spots
to the proper priority queues and also
making sure to put them in the right
size queue right so for example if it's
a small parking spot we need to make
sure to put it in the small parking
queue okay and we're doing that of
course based on the distance from
entrance I if you recall from The
Parking Spot class we have the distances
to each entry and so we're basically
using that field to assemble those cues
phew so I know that's a lot but we're
still going let's go ahead and get
through this the easy method to
implement is actually getting the number
of spots so basically we only really
need to consider you know one set of
cues here so basically looking at this
from entrance zero we go through all of
those priority cues uh for you know
small medium and big cars we Loop
through those and then we create a
dictionary which basically says um you
know dictionary of the small key has 100
spots dictionary of the medium key has
50 spots etc etc so easy enough for
getting the number of spots the more
complicated part is the entry and the
exit methods and I'm going to go through
those now
okay so let's imagine we're calling
enter And We have basically the size of
the incoming car we have the entry
number that we're going through and we
also have the license plate number of
the incoming card so the first thing
that we're going to do is figure out the
proper priority queue to go ahead and
check in order to remove an element from
that priority queue so that priority
queue is going to be the one
corresponding to the entry number that
we're coming through also with the
proper car size then we're going to go
ahead and find the top element of that
priority queue which is the spot that we
know that we're going to be taking so we
can do that by peaking at our priority
queue we also get the name of that spot
so that we can use it in our actual hash
Maps itself later when we're removing
that element from all the priority
queues we then go ahead and use the car
map because we know that our car map is
basically mapping license plate numbers
to the spot that they're in so that we
can vacate it later and so we're going
to set that element in the car map
and then finally for every single
priority queue we have to now remove
this parking spot and so we go through
the priority queues basically in code
say okay find the element
um or basically find the index of the
array in the priority queue that this
parking spot is located at and we have
that from our parking spot hashmap we go
ahead and do that remove those all from
the priority queue so those are all
going to be a logarithmic time
complexity operations and once we've
removed that parking spot from every
single priority queue for each entrance
we can go ahead and move on to our
actual exit method
okay so now the exit method is pretty
much symmetrical to the entry method but
instead of this time removing that
parking spot from all the priority
queues now we have to go ahead and add
it back to all of the priority queues
which is pretty annoying but it's a
similar thing so the first thing we do
is we know that we have a given license
plate number and as a result we can
quickly go into the car map to find out
which spot it was that that car was
occupying then we can go through all of
the priority queues for each entrance
and basically say we're going to figure
out the index number we're basically
going to add this spot back into all of
the priority queues figure out the index
in the array of the priority queue that
they were added to and put that back in
our hash map in the event that we have
to remove this spot from all the
priority queues later
okay well I hope that makes sense guys I
understand that this is kind of abstract
as far as algorithms go
um but again there are many many
different types of possible
implementations that you can do and
frankly kind of the concept of having
multiple entrances and exits with
priority cues like that is not a simple
thing and I don't think anyone would
expect you to code that out in an
interview
um but the general gist of this video is
you know thinking about what parts of
the parking garage actually need to
store State and which don't and in this
case you know you don't need an entry
class you don't need an exit class you
don't need vehicle classes just having
an implementation of a parking garage
for the logic surrounding which spot to
give as well as actually having
implementations for parking spot objects
in order to store the state of whether
or not they're occupied should be
sufficient for this problem
alrighty everyone I hope you all enjoyed
uh shout out Xavier Zhao who has asked
me to make this video and I'm coming
through on my promise buddy
um yeah but uh do expect me to sell out
in the near future as I continue to run
out of video ideas but for now let's
keep busting through low-level design